الكاتب المصري عبد الرحيم كمال تحدث عبر
حسابه حول الاهانه التي يتعرض لها
الفنانون حاليا القى اللوم على الانترنت
الذي كسر الحاجز بين الفنان والجمهور وجعل
الاساءه امرا طبيعيا في حين ان الفنان لا
يملكوا ميزه النجديه فقط كان ذلك في يناير
الماضي بعد صدور فيلم اصحاب ولا اعز عندما
كانت الفنانه منى زكي هدفا مستباحا امام
الجمهور بسبب مشهدا صنف على انه يخالف
المعايير المجتمعيه عبر انستغرام نشرت
الفنانه لقاء الخميس في مقاطع تناشد فيها
متابعها باحترام الاختلاف والخلفيه التي
جاء منها الناس دون اهانه او تقليل وقالت
ان الفنان مجرد انسان يسعد ويتاثر بالظروف
من الممكن ان يمر بازمات اسريه الفنانه
بشرى دعمت لقاء عبر حسابها وقالت ان
الفنانين نبض المجتمع مش الحيطه المايله
بتاعه المجتمع لقاء هاجمت ايضا الصحافه
المجتزازيه التي تستطيع الكلام بحثا عن
تراند على حده
رساله
للصحفيين اللي بيحبوا يكتبوا الاخبار عشان
يعملوا ترندات ويعملوا حاجه حراقه علشان
يبقى فيه
ناس كثير بتدخل والخبر يبقى تكتب الخبر
كامل وصح كما قيل لما تكتبوش وتحترم نفسك
ده رقم واحد رقم اثنين رجاء من كل ال ال
ال
الناس اللي بتتابع سوشيال دي يا جماعه
اللي بيحب حد يدخل عنده ويقول له كلمتين
حلوين او ليصمت ما بتحبش ما تدخلش ممكن
تختلف في الاراء ممكن نختلف لكن لازم
نتعلم ازاي نحترم الاختلاف الى اي مدى
بالفعل الجمهور له الحق في انتقاد الفنانه
في الراي يبرر الهجوم هو شخصا النقد الى
التجريح
فعلا الفنانه اللقاء ولكن هنا لازم نفرق
ما بين حاجتين كلمه النقد والانتقاد النقد
ده ناقد بيتكلم بي- بيشوف همم مسلسل او
عمل فني ويقدر ان هو يعني ينقد مش ينطقد
ينقد عناصر العمل يتعرض لها بالايجاب
والسلب ولكن هناك فرق ما بين الانتقاد
الانتقاد انا بانتقد انسان قدامي عامل
ازاي باحبه باكرهه ده انطباعات للاسف خلال
العشرين سنه الاخيره او ال 15 سنه الاخيره
قوه السوشيال ميديا دخلت عناصر اخرى غير
النقاد المؤهلين بمعنى ان اي واحد
النهارده يمتلك صفحه على فيسبوك ممكن يشتم
فنان او فنانه او هو عاجبه او مش عاجبه زي
ما الدنيا تمشي فهنا بيحصل جاب لابد ان
احنا نبقى عارفين ان انا لما بقيم فنان
بقيم فنيا اما الحياه الشخصيه هناك خط
فاصل ما بين الحياه الشخصيه والحياه
العامه بالنسبه للفنان طيب همم
مقاطع كلام الفنان بحث اذا الى مادباتهانت
هوس المتابعين هاوس المشاهدات اليوم مشكله
احنا دلوقت في زمن الترند في هواس غير
طبيعي مع انتشار اولا المواقع الاخباريه
او ال- ال- الاساسيه اللي هي دلوقت ما
عادتش الصحف المحافظه بقت المواقع الاخ هي
وكمان مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الاثنين
كده حصل ما بينهم اندماج فبقى دلوقتي
البحث عن الترند بحث عن الترند هو اجزاء
اي همم حديث او حوار واخذ كلمه منه وتطلع
ترن سواء كانت مع او كانت الضد بعض
الفنانين لابد ان هو او الفنانين لا لازم
يبقى عارف برده ان هو شخصيه عامه تصرفاته
الطبيعيه تحت المجهر لكن ما اجيش النهارده
مع بعض الفنانين بيبحثوا على الترند هم
كمان يعني ما جيش النهارده في مهرجان وفي
فنانه جايه لابسه همم زي ما حصل وايه يعني
ما كانتش ال- ال- اللبس بتاعها جيد ولما
تسالت قالت والله نسيت البطانه ده كلام ما
هي جايه تبحث عن ترنج
[موسيقى]